[Musique]
bleu sous le soleil move devant les yeux
de ce pêcheur ou grises et agité
l'aquarelliste fabrice moi reconnaît
tous les visages de la loire car il la
scruter depuis son plus jeune âge c'est
ma loire parce que moi je suis né à mer
dans un petit à petit village l'a bien
connu entre blois et orléans et la loire
g j'ai toujours connu ça fait cinquante
quatre ans que je la connais et je ça
toujours été pour moi comme une commune
personnes on allait voir
il faut pas dire aux cheveux c'est pas
mourante la loire mais l'été on va voir
si elle est basse l'hiver on va voir
comment elle est le lendemain retour
parce qu'on sait jamais et puis on va
voir les poissons et puis on veut voir
tout voir tout ce qui peut avoir bougé
de la veille et sérieusement la loire a
toujours été pour moi comme une personne
une espèce de personnes sans âge très
grande très forte
l'étrange mystérieuse au possible alors
évidemment la peindre quand je suis
devenu plus grand
ça a été une satisfaction et une
obligation même
fabrice moreau se qualifie lui-même de
réaliste un tiède impressionnisme saloir
qu'il va débusquer jusque dans le passé
de sa marine fluviale
il la photographie du regard pour en
restituer la vérité du moment sous forme
de boutade je dis aux gens je suis
photographe impressionniste bien souvent
les gens qui sont pas versés dans les
arts me disent on dirait une photo alors
au début je me braquer parce que c'est
toujours un peu péjoratif quand on a
fait des écoles d'art et quand qu'on
s'entend dire ça tout de suite dans ce
braquage
puis après j'ai vu de la bonhomie là
dedans de la gentillesse en fête et de
l'admiration dans le fait de la capter
quelque chose aussi de façon aussi juste
comme je le fais je pense les couleurs
tout ça sa frappe les gens
évanescente ou suggestives la loire de
fabrice moreau est une madeleine de
proust
un voyage intérieur à usage de tous les
ligériens
[Musique]